Gentlemen.
All right, E Streeters!
Let's do this thing.
We're, uh, sitting at Thrill Hill Recording in
the wilds of New Jersey
having reconvened the E Street Band.
When you get back together it's just a power
it's like a family reuniting.
Real friends for forty-years
all contributing something artistically.
That's something special.
The greatest thrill in my life is
standing behind that microphone
with you guys behind me.
Let's do it.
There's, uh, a terrific, unspoken,
kind of affinity
for what we're about to do.
♪♪
We showed up
with no demos sent
no chance to write out charts and get to know the songs.
The way we do things,
capturing the excitement while it's happening.
The only other time we worked this way
would be Born In The U.S.A.
When we play together, it's 1977
all over again.
It's all about the songs, right?
And the inspiration for those songs
comes from what I know
you guys are gonna be playing.
♪♪
You're not exactly sure where you're going.
But, you know if you jump onto his energy,
and his direction
you'll get there together.
You're holding on to just learn the basic song
and then even Bruce is kind of
changing his mind about things.
Don't play it up higher, just don't play so low.
♪♪
But invariably...
Let's get the claps
and get the la da da's.
...it will trigger an idea.
♪♪
It's just gotten better, blows my mind.
Bruce is one of the great songwriters in history.
♪♪
It's the journey not so much the destination.
And him recognizing that
is why he's a great artist.
♪♪
There's a moment where it all comes together, and it's fleeting.
I've heard it described as catching lightning in a bottle.
And that's catching the magic.
♪♪
Perfect!